but ever probability by name is a word
that we usually associate not with
probability but with polynomials right
and that's why we were looking at
expansions earlier in the year but as it
turns out and you can always kind of
anticipate them you know what we're
doing probability and arrangements often
what we're doing is we're stringing
things together multiplying things
together and that's kind of the same
building block as polynomial so then it
should be that surprising that they
actually come together in this unusual
way okay so we're going to look at how
to tackle questions from building
questions that require this specific
technique and it is a very specific
technique you can almost always tackle a
probability question that you can use
this on in other ways they're almost
certainly other ways but where it's
relevant these are the fastest okay now
here's the deep these questions they
don't come up with a you know big
flashing lights and this is a binomial
probability question you yourself have
to know when by Dover probability is
appropriate and there are two things you
need to look for two qualities or maybe
three firstly we're looking at
multistage events that's kind of a given
like in extension one all of the
interesting stuff is multistage okay we
want this and this and this together
okay so the first thing on this baby
secularly all the stages they have to be
identical I'll let you have a think
about why as we progress through this
example I'm going to give you why the
stages have to be identical otherwise
this thing this part of it breaks down
okay last stage and this is implied by
the name for each stage not only are
they all the same but they all have to
have only two outcomes only two possible
outcomes for each stage okay now as you
see the second even though many
situations inherently have multiple
outcomes like saying throwing a die okay
depending on the situation you get given
depending on the probability you get
asked for you remember what we said
before about on a problem well phrased
is half solved well you can often phrase
it in terms of
only two outcomes okay so let's do an
example and I'll go with the die and
suppose what we want to do is we just
want to work out how many um how many
fires we can get fires okay that's all
we're interested in okay so even though
a die is an a6 outcome situation right
I'm just thinking it in terms of two
outcomes namely fives or not fires
okay fives or not fives so here's our
probability tree I've drawn it out with
with three levels okay three is pretty
much as much as you're expected to do in
an exam really as you start to go
further it's us to become a bit
impractical just to draw the diagram but
as you will see one of the strengths of
this technique is that you can use it
without a diagram if you understand
what's going on so very quickly just to
start off with let's just create the
diagram because I'm gonna refer to a few
things here so I'm gonna start with
fives right there's one alternative and
not fires okay
so just like Libya coin I suppose I'll
fill it out and you can do the same now
let's consider this I'm not going to
give us any particular questions we can
sort of build our own questions out of a
situation like this okay for instance a
classic kind of thing to ask would be
what's the probability what's the
probability so many markets what's the
probability of all fires that would be a
pretty straightforward question to ask
you right now we don't need anything in
our previous like permutations
combinations kind of knowledge to solve
this particular question right all fires
comedy of these in my sample space of
eight how many of these options are the
ones I'm interested in which one's the
favorable ones just this one at the top
right that's the only one I'm interested
in it and of course you just use the
product rule to work out what the
probability will be right now this is
the important thing right you got two
outcomes but they're not equal obviously
they're not equal right what are the
probabilities on these branches going to
be I see
right okay and of course you can fill in
all the five sixes
they don't long with that but it gets a
bit tiresome pretty quickly okay so I'm
only going to pull my stuff that I need
so therefore this probability is easy
this is just one six cubed no problems
which of course is not especially likely
one 216 okay but let's think about other
different options here okay for instance
that was the probability of getting all
fives right
the probability of getting no fives
probably gained no feist he's gonna be a
different probability obviously but it's
just as easy to work out okay so I'm
just gonna skip that for a second okay
what about well what would you like to
pose it's in this kind of situation what
would be a natural other question that
you might get asked what's the point of
setting at least one five okay we'll get
to at least one five in a second let's
just take a simpler case which is one
five okay one fun cuz that's got a
couple of cases two or three cases in
okay if I say the probability of one
flag exactly one five okay now in this
case because I picked out you know only
a number of branches where it's quite
easy to count you can literally see it
you don't have to do any fancy sort of
stuff to work out how many of these
options will fit back right which are
then returning one five I can see a five
here yeah I can see what five here and
then so there's three you can count that
up fairly easily right but like I said
if I expanded this out if I just went
one more time you don't have a total
ptosis you've got sixteen and if I go
another time you're 32 you can't draw
the diagram
you can't count reliably in a in a time
efficient way surely we can work out a
better way of working out or had why is
it 3 is just 3 randomly it's not me
randomly right why is it 3 where is the
3 come from
now to get the answer that question
think about this you've got this
question that we posed there's one five
do we mind when the five is rolled do we
mind we don't care right you could roll
it you can roll it first or in the
middle or you could roll at last okay
so therefore in terms of our
arrangements language is this talking
about permutations or is it talking
about combinations are you sure good
you are sure not cuz I tell you yes of
course it's combinations cause I don't
care about order these are all the same
that's all I'm interested in right so
therefore this is not just three it's
not just that there are three ways to
get this it's that air are three choose
one ways to get this right look you've
got three different things to choose
from
three five to choose from but I only
want one of them I don't care where he
goes I don't care where he goes right
that's why it's three C 1 naught 3 P 1
does that make sense in fact in this
whole situation I don't really care
about order at all I just want well I
want one of them somewhere okay so
orders not important to me
right no there are 3 C 1 ways to get 1/5
ok well let's have a look at one of them
let's have a look at a this one using
the protocol just like we did before
what's the probably of just this event
just this event well if I follow the UM
if I follow the change through I started
here then this one's gonna be five sixes
and then this one it's gonna be five
suits so probability of just this
instance is a 6 times 5 6 times 5 6 no
problem ok and when you have a look at
the next instance I mean we can work
this out but we don't need to do it
right because like I said I just want
this I don't care about the order right
and every branch is identical right
every every set of events so all I need
to do is just take these same numbers
and rearrange them that's how I'll get
this
we're gonna get them not five first and
they don't get the fine and then I'll
get the not five again right and of
course you don't need this last one
they're all going to be the same okay
so therefore what I've got here to put
them all together is I've got three
trees well ways to get one five and then
when I think about the probability of
each of those ways it's gonna be well
you've got to get a five and that's the
probability of a five and you've got to
get two of them being not five does that
make sense so let me let me sort of this
is the number of ways right this is the
probability of just getting a single
five okay and these are the
probabilities of getting a not five and
I want to dot fives because I only have
one five sorry turi numbers you've
always have fun is that all right okay
now with that going ahead and drawing it
onto the diagram you can probably
anticipate what's gonna happen if I say
well what if I want two fives how would
you build this taking this pattern here
instead of going to the diagram which in
this situation is just barely doable but
as we expand out the number of stages
starts to become not worth it right I've
got three components three components
right but first I want to work out well
how many ways is this possible right
how many Arrangements is valuable here
are favourable and the answer is 3
choose 2 because I want two fires right
now what will be the probability of all
of these different ways added up
together well probably your five is a
six and I'm gonna get two of those in
what order doesn't matter okay I'm just
gonna get two of them yeah and then of
course you're gonna have one of the
numbers not being fire so that's the
probability there so in fact this is the
same thing
just for a different scenario okay sir
have a think about that now if you put
together I've got one case you there's
one case left right and that was the one
we um we said right in the beginning
which is that they could be both - I
didn't do it in a very good okay okay
but we can we can build this up right
I'm gonna do it the same way three
choose how many zero I don't want any
now alternatively I suppose you could
say it's gonna be three choose three
right because I'm choosing three not
fires we've got symmetry here doesn't
matter they're the same okay how many
lots of a sixth am I going to get none
of them because because this is the
probability of five and I don't have any
right and then of course I've got three
of they're not fires and we already know
what that probability is going to be
okay so now you can actually see that
this even though it's correct right it's
missing bits it's missing the fact that
actually how many ways are there to get
all fives and the answer is there's one
way for three choose three right and
then of course there's all of the not
fires here but there are none of them so
that's why they don't factor in this is
one and this is one which what is why we
can get away with outlining okay now
this is all the cases right this is the
whole expansion so if I add all of these
up what would you expect again this is
all the total events right everything
suicide if I said what's the probability
of any of these happening well one of
them has to happen right so the
probability one okay but you can see if
you add these up this is where this
comes in right if you add up all these
together what is this this is the
expansion of something what's the
expansion of
we said this is equal to one right okay
because you add them all up from a
probability point of view they all have
to add up to one but what it is is well
you know here's your a and here's your B
write a six plus five six and then these
powers here this one this one this one
this one they all add up to three of
course they add up to three right so
when you expand this out you've got one
of the first one three and then three
and then one just like you would expect
from Pascal's triangle okay but of
course you know you could just add them
up and keep it and you get one right so
there you go the polynomial comes in
when you consider all of the cases
together Salatin's